there are many mysteries locked within
the walls of the scp foundation from
potentially world-ending scenarios to
the minds of monsters like the hard to
destroy reptile day after day the
research staff worked tirelessly to
unravel these secrets contain them and
when necessary terminate them but what
about another researcher another man of
science trying desperately to uncover
the truth today we'll put down the
clipboards and white lab coats in favor
of black robes a beaked mask or rather
skull and a seemingly endless doctor's
bag to take a look at the average day
for one peculiar physician
scp-049 the plague doctor we took the
liberty of turning the researcher into
the research subject watching scp-049 as
he went about his daily life from his
inscrutable experiments to his strange
habits it was difficult to chronicle
without tipping the good doctor off as
to what we're up to but we were able to
get everything we needed to make the
video you're watching right now welcome
friends enemies and future patients to a
day in the life of scp-049
am the great dying never sleeps and
neither really does the plague doctor
unlike ordinary human doctors he does
not need to get his eight hours of shut
eye in order to function properly the
sharp mind of scp-049 never dulls no
matter how long he is awake of course he
does occasionally lie down in his
containment cell arms crossed over his
chest like a mummy breathing at a
noticeably slower pace for several hours
however he does not appear to actually
enter a rem cycle nor does his behavior
change when he is denied this rest time
it would appear he is simply for a lack
of a better term brainstorming for a
little while before getting up to start
the new day back when he lived on the
outside
he would rise to the sound of a
rooster's crow or the ringing of church
bells in the town square but now we
discovered the plague doctor becomes
active for the day at exactly 6 am on
the dot we're not sure how he manages
such precision since there are no clocks
visible from his room but then again
there's a lot we still don't understand
about him but whether you wake to the
sound of a buzzing phone alarm or your
own perfectly tuned internal clock
there's nothing wrong with getting a
nice early start on your day's tasks
just like he doesn't need sleep the
plague doctor does not rely on steady
caloric intake for his energy instead he
is sustained by the satisfaction of
doing what needs to be done but that
doesn't mean he can't eat he enjoys
starting the day with breakfast often
consisting of toasted bread with butter
jam or honey if he's feeling
particularly indulgent sometimes all
three and he washes it down with an
espresso or cup of steaming hot lavender
tea though he's a serious man he
understands the importance of treating
yourself first thing in the morning it
sets the tone for the day and gives him
the boost he'll need for what's to come
8 am some people enjoy a long languid
morning routine they shower they do
their 11 step skin care regimen they do
some gentle stretching to wake up their
muscles and circular system
scp-049 is not one of those people he is
a no must no fuss type through and
through besides with gloves robes and a
mask that are parts of his physical body
it is uncertain if he has any skin that
needs caring for or produces sweat that
might need to be washed away we're not
sure if you can use korean sheet masks
on kaiten but we really don't think that
the plague doctor would let us try with
no hygiene to worry about it's time for
scp-049 to get going on his favorite
activity the one that borders on all
encompassing obsession working towards a
cure for the great dying the pestilence
that he has devoted his existence to
fighting once upon a time the foundation
was so kind as to offer him corpses to
experiment on but given the doctor's
penchant for resurrecting the dead and
turning them into mindless zombies that
follow his every command they decided to
do away with that particular program you
can't always get what you want
especially when what you want results in
an army of the undead living test
subjects won't work either because his
deadly touch and his tendency toward
shall we say unconventional surgical
methods it's just not the best idea so
what's a doc to do his best with what
he's got of course around this time of
morning he sets up a neat row of tools
and implements on his favorite workbench
and selects various tissue samples to
dissect to inject with solutions and
dissolve in jars to study from every
angle he can until he finally cracks the
cure to the pestilence 10 am the work
may be his top priority but no man is an
island even a man who isn't quite human
needs to engage in polite conversation
we do still live in a society after all
after working in silence for a couple of
hours the plague doctor has gotten into
the habit of talking to whoever happens
to be passing by his containment
facility sometimes it's a custodian
mopping up blood stains sometimes it's a
doctor he can engage with about their
mutual love of science and research
sometimes it's another scp one of the
few lucky permitted to roam about the
facility without much supervision today
it was
scp-507 the reluctant dimension hopper
back from his latest involuntary travel
to another world he was wearing a pair
of cargo shorts and a t-shirt emblazoned
with a variety of comic book characters
he approached the window of scp-049's
containment cell with a cheerful wave
hey doc how's it going he smiled oh
hello
the doctor's eyes shone excitedly from
the depths of his mask how nice it is to
see you i'm having a most productive day
and you how did you fare on your voyage
you were looking well i presume it was
successful the plague doctor wasn't
exactly sure what this friendly man got
up to when he was away from the
foundation perhaps he was a merchant or
a cartographer charting foreign lands
one of the white-coated scientists had
attempted to explain it to him but was
called away by more important affairs
before he could have his questions
answered
scp-507 shuddered at the question
not my favorite his face paled at the
memory
i don't want to get into it too much but
i'll just say this spiders
lots and lots of spiders i'm quite sorry
to hear that may your next destination
be a better one
scp-507's frown dissolved into a grin at
the doctor's words appreciate it doc
well we'll see i guess i'm gonna go ask
god some questions about what happens
when we die good luck with the science
stuff he pressed a palm to the glass
inviting the plague doctor to give him a
high five through the window haltingly a
bit confused about the gesture the
doctor pressed his hand to the glass in
return see around indeed the doctor
waved as the friendly blonde man headed
off to explore his own mortality and
probably make a smoothie 12 p.m right at
noon the doctor pauses his work to enjoy
a nice lunch like all of his meals his
food is delivered through a slot in the
door his lunch consists mostly often of
a wedge of hard cheese a small bunch of
grapes and some goose liver pate with
crackers frequently he will ask to join
the staff and other freely moving
anomalies in the cafeteria but due to
safety concerns he is not permitted to
do so the last thing we need is him
brushing hands with someone while
reaching for an extra scoop of mashed
potatoes and them dropping dead right
there on the tile floor still it is
lonely for him to eat in there watching
the rest of the staff walk to lunch
gabbing about their weekends and
discussing what the soup of the day
might be on this day the plague doctor
was having an especially frustrating
lunch as he nibbled delicately on his
cheese he heard a twinkling melody in
the distance very very faint coming from
somewhere outside suddenly there was a
flurry of activity in the hall as
foundation employees made their way
towards the source of the music excuse
me he called to a passing security guard
what is all the commotion about dr
wright stole an ice cream truck free ice
cream for everyone the woman cried
giddily
what a treat might i request you procure
a cup for me too but before he could
finish his question she was already gone
yelling don't take all the strawberry
before i get there
scp-049 watched beak pressed against the
glass as a parade of people walked past
carrying cones ice cream bars bowls
piled high with ice cream scoops hot
fudge nuts and cherries it seemed like
everyone was enjoying their ice cream
cooling down on a hot day with a sweet
treat except for him even some of the
other scps were getting in on the fun
scp-999 oozed by the door holding a
chocolate vanilla swirl cone a sundae
and a chocolate covered frozen banana it
paused at the side of the doctor's sad
expression making an inquisitive
gurgling sound good afternoon dear
creature it seems i've been left out of
the festivities the plague doctor's side
the tickle monster gurgled again sliding
over to the slot in the door
he trailed off as the slimy little
friend eased the slot open and pushed
the sundae and plastic spoon inside the
sundae spilled a little bit on its way
in but remained mostly intact
thank you i am ever in your debt the
plague doctor exclaimed the tickle
monster was already departing off to
brighten someone else's day no matter
someone had remembered him and for once
he didn't mind being prohibited from
eating in the canteen even from his cell
he was still a part of things 1 30 p.m
every so often the plague doctor
experiences a joyous break in his
routine he is given a test subject not a
human subject of course or even a living
subject but a fresh organic specimen
nonetheless as a reward for good
behavior and incentive to continue
cooperating with the foundation staff
scp-049 is occasionally given a deceased
animal specimen to dissect and
experiment on in this particular case it
was a large adult cow that i'm told
passed away from natural causes after a
life of grazing happily in the sun as
the cow's body was wheeled into his
containment cell by a group of
researchers clad in hazmat suits the
plague doctor clasped his gloved hands
together excitedly one of the
researchers leaned over to another and
whispered i thought this was for sloppy
joe day his colleague solemnly shook his
head i here you go doctor another piped
up marvelous thank you gentlemen thank
you as cp049 exclaimed he was so
overcome with delight that he patted one
of the researchers on the back the man
tensed for a moment terrified at the
sudden physical contact but relaxed when
he remembered that his protective gear
protected him from the deadly effects of
a touch from the plague doctor
yeah
you got it buddy the man let out a sigh
of relief heart's still racing are you
feeling quite alright my friend the
doctor cocked his head to the side
watching the man's face closely you seem
troubled perhaps i should provide you
with a cursory examination i would hate
to see my benefactor fall ill
i'm fine uh fine just uh
a little tired lots to do can't stay
gotta get to the next thing the man
laughed nervously come on let's go he
hissed to his colleagues rushing towards
the exit they followed never taking
their eyes off the plague doctor as they
went
story will remember your contribution to
the advancement of medical science the
doctor said solemnly waving goodbye to
the men as they left and resealed the
door to the room
4pm
eureka cried the plague doctor after a
moment its eyes opened and it let out a
warped strange mooing sound that echoed
down the halls it stumbled to its feet
milky eyes rolling around in its head as
it took its first breath since it passed
away the cow had been brought back to
life but like all the patients the
doctor had successfully cured so far it
was not quite right it swelled and
bulged in strange places black slime
dribbled from its nostrils and mouth and
it shuffled around the small room
aimlessly waiting for guidance as it
locked eyes with the researcher walking
past looking at it through the glass it
let out another moo chomping its teeth
in anticipation of a bite like anyone
else briefed on the containment
procedures for scp-049
this man knew that any resurrections
were strictly off-limits for the anomaly
no matter how proud the plague doctor
was of his little project for the day he
could not be allowed to keep it it would
be confiscated and terminated he called
for his supervisor and soon a group of
armed guards were bursting through the
door tipping the zombie cow on her side
like a group of rural teens on a rowdy
night out all the while the plague
doctor shouted at them how dare you
unhand her immediately but the guards
did not listen they injected the cow
with enough tranquilizers to knock out a
herd of elephants and hauled it out of
the room towards the incinerator alone
in his room the plague doctor sat with
his head in his hands making the sound
of crying though no tears could be seen
running down his masked face we talked
about this doctor a senior researcher
spoke to him through the window you
can't have reanimated corpses in your
cell it's a security concern she was my
first breakthrough in months he wailed
with a sigh the senior researcher
pressed a button to aid in calming the
distressed anomaly down a hissing sound
filled the containment cell as the scent
of fresh lavender was pumped into the
space the doctor lifted his head taking
a deep breath and slowly relaxing his
shoulders very well please do me one
favor my friend
bring me her brain i can do that the
senior researcher nodded but you can't
do this again or will have to revoke
your test subject privileges again my
work is not a privilege it is a calling
a necessity the doctor pounded a gloved
fist on the floor all right of course
let me get that brain for you 7 pm
sometime mid-evening the plague doctor's
meal slot opens again as his dinner is
pushed through for him to enjoy today's
supper is roasted potatoes and onions a
cut of baked fish more crusty bread and
a small cup of fragrant red wine on
special occasions he is even able to
request a second glass of wine to wash
down the troubles of the day after the
cow incident this is not one of those
days so he drinks his one allotted cup
slowly savoring it along with his food
most culinary enthusiasts would suggest
against red wine with fish but the
plague doctor does not live by the rules
of man he makes his own 8pm after his
dinner scp-049 begins tidying his
workspace preparing to wind down for the
night he wipes down his work table
clearing it of blood sweat and other
mysterious liquids he returns his
various tools to their home in his
doctor's bag sealing the lids on his
jars and placing them back inside he
works hard but one cannot work all the
time rest taking the time for deep
thought and processing all that he has
learned throughout the day is just as
vital 10 pm to end the day the plague
doctor engages in one of his few simple
pleasures he reads he has requested and
been provided various texts from the
foundation ranging from the medical to
the literary he has a compendium of the
writings of hippocrates pliny the elders
texts of medicine and natural science as
well as some modern scientific texts he
has largely disregarded for lighter
reading he has set aside the canterbury
tales lady chatterley's lover the lover
by marguerite duras and madame bovrei it
seems that when it comes to his fiction
the plague doctor has a bit of a
romantic side he lies on his back
reading by the overhead light listening
as the sounds of the foundation quiet
down for the night the once bustling
facility now has only the occasional
footsteps the sounds of doors closing
and machinery being powered down as
those who can go home to their lives on
the outside do but
scp-049 is not one of them he has always
lived for the science for the work and
now he lives in a research facility full
time it may not be an ideal life but he
has found a way to make do with it and
tomorrow he will go up against his
greatest enemy the illness he has sworn
to cure once again and there you have it
folks a day in the life of the
mysterious masked physician is there
anything from the plague doctor's daily
routine that you think you might want to
start incorporating into your own day to
day lives let us know down in the
comments sometimes no matter how distant
success may seem we just have to keep
working toward our goals no one
exemplifies that better than the oh so
determined scp-049
and his tireless attempts to rid the
world of the pestilence once and for all
sure his methods aren't always the most
helpful but everybody makes mistakes the
most important thing is to try your best
now go check out when daybreaks
scp-049 and kidnap by scp-049 for more
tales about everyone's favorite masked
doctor